hey everyone
welcome
my name is atlas i'm the host
of simulation this youtube channel
where we uncover the nature of reality
consciousness and maximizing
human potential
i will be doing my best to
elaborate on some of
our metaphysics using
art so
as you can see in the notes right now
the first thing is that we want to
balance
perpetual kindergarten and metaphysical
insight so that would look something
like
this where
you have
what i would say metaphysics
outweighing kindergarten
and the reason why is because there are
not
enough people that even take the
big risk to take a stab
at what they think the nature of reality
is and there are many many people
who choose to stay in perpetual
kindergarten so i would say it's more
important
to take the stab at what you think the
nature of reality is
but keep it balanced with that love for
perpetual
kindergarten along the way
so next is to be
aware of the bucket of crabs
which is an analogy for
the evolutionary pacer
so as you know
in high level perception
we specifically made this graphic
to illustrate to you that
the center of the bell curve
is very frequently
attempting to pull
the entrepreneurs the artists the
leaders and especially the genius
visionaries that are several standard
deviations up the bell curve that are
attempting to deploy
code updates as portals to the rest
of civilization to augment our
perception
and code that that evolutionary pacer
typically acts
like a bucket of crabs trying to
pull down the geniuses trying to escape
out of the neuroticism of the pacer
and trying create a game b
omni win civilization design
so it's important to stay resilient
all right next is
to encourage those that are trying
so
we know that the people that are
frequently like nicholas copernicus
that are thinking in the point
one percent on the genius code updates
are mutants in many ways
and that they need to be encouraged and
that we need
even better incentive structures
and encouragement and systemization
of genius in our social fabric
and that last point under
module a that first
bit is that we must simplify
we must use art
as i and many
others are getting too many 100 page
metaphysics
reports so
as you know we have people
like
m.c escher
who were able to
bring things like this into our universe
and what happens is that through
explain like i'm five art
we can distill recursion we can distill
the self simulation
we can distill cyclic cosmology
it's very very important
to use art rather than 100 page
metaphysical reports
all right that's the future of
communication
especially to gen z and generation alpha
the most powerful mimetics
will be disseminated via
compressions and distillations of
the
most abstract genius level meta patterns
of
metaphysics consciousness maximizing
human potential
and we plan on in 2021 and beyond doing
that via animations
and series and anthologies and
documentaries and much
much more all right
on we go to the
module b
all right so in module b
my thoughts are that the actual nature
of reality
needs to be a couple things
i think that it should be integral
imaginative and cyclic
and i know that there are many people
that are attempting to
to do this from a
mathematics and physics and
artificial intelligence and theory of
everything perspective
in that lens and i highly respect them
as well people like eric weinstein and
stephen wolfram
and thomas campbell and many others
and i highly respect
their metaphysics
and mine is more
artistic and i find it very
interesting that the word artistic and
autistic are
that similar to one another
and that
i would respect at a deeper level all
people that are attempting to make these
genius level metaphysics and try and
disseminate them as
portals to the evolutionary
pacer so we'll go back to
some of these thoughts again so the
integral
is going to include everything
especially purpose and so that's
up here and so here's the integral
including everything and
the second one is we want to stretch the
imagination
to its limits that's that light bulb
and that we want to incorporate infinity
eternity and consciousness
in the oro boros signals that
so you
notice how i specifically
mention that especially purpose
is important we've now become very
familiar with
simon sinek start with why it's a very
powerful
three words and
it helps a lot
for us to determine our
self-actualization north stars as
individuals in the symphony
playing our unique melodies and
instruments
but on a self realization
level that
we must also identify the purpose
what is the purpose of these realities
existing
and what would that look like if we
incorporated
infinity eternity
into that equation and if we used our
biggest imagination even beyond
walt disney even beyond pixar
beyond star wars and star trek
beyond the world's best artists mcs sure
gaudi beyond
dali go beyond kalo go beyond
and in that process what will happen is
you will slowly
become more and more awake
to what metaphysics are actually
possible
because we spend a lot of our time
constrained
without actually expressing the fullest
capacity of our imagination
all right again integral imaginative and
cyclic
okay now we will unpack
module c
all right so in module c
these are my thoughts on the actual
nature of
reality and they
are color coded which will be very
helpful
so let's go ahead and start with
that first point so number one
is the oroboros tail
all right so that's right here
we see tail right there oroboros tail
okay number two
is the big bang so that's right there
the next one
and i very specifically talk about
how the
that big bang is actually
the designed realities
that are deployed meaning that
we actually come from the
metaverse and that we designed
these realities
and again this is a hypothesis about
the nature of reality
of what i think the and feel the actual
nature of reality is
and so that's why
the tale and the godhead
both partake in that metaverse and so
we are the publishers and players
okay so
next is the
source code automata
and that's that primal soup
that comes from the big bang
as many cosmologists and physicists talk
about
those very early stages
and that that primal soup source code
becomes a self making
over time as we see
with the billions of years of
cosmological evolution
that produce the
earth approximately four and a half
billion years ago
which then produces
approximately three and a half billion
years ago
the single cellular life
which then becomes multicellular life
which then
slowly over time evolves to become
us and so i will
also explain number
four which i think is extremely
important
it's usually very very
underrepresented in conversations
about the nature of reality and
existence
and so we have to realize that
it is not an accident that
we are on a rock
and so this sentience was secreted
on this rock and that the rock
is bound gravitationally
and orbiting a star 93 million miles
away
across a very inhospitable
vacuum of space and so
because of that what we see
is a a forcing
function of being bounded to the rock
because as we hypothesize about
consciousness exploring infinity as our
metaphysics
which means the map is unbounded
that's why we are eternally exploring
infinity because we can never finish
whereas in this scenario the secretion
of sentience is
bounded it's bounded
to the rock
and although we have all of our great
cosmological
pursuits to
settle across the cosmos
on other celestial bodies like the moon
and the mars
which are great pursuits which are fun
and exhilarating explorations
the transcension hypothesis of
john smart of going inward
into the metaverse will likely
happen at the same time as we do that
pursuit out as well
so
we mentioned number five
which is the
secretion of sentience
which is right here and so that is
us and there's lots of
other evidence about
sentience also being present
in the other approximately 10 million
species that exist on the planet
as many of us are very familiar with the
dogs and cats that we have as pets with
the animals
that exists throughout the biological
kingdom
as well as even plants
and fungi
having intelligence so
this is very interesting to see it
from a perspective that is more
holistic and less
simply driven by just
the idea of humans
being it
so six
is that over time the
mapping of chaos
that big big map that we have that we
were discussing
that map of reality
becomes more and more ordered so
we order the chaos that big map
of chaos becomes more ordered
and another important thing about the
bounding function
is that it creates
the interactions of conscious agents
with each other increase
because of that bounding function so
conscious agents
are forced to engage and interact with
one another
and that's why over the period of
evolutionary
time as we explored the actual
planet what occurred is that
humans ended up running into one another
and there were issues with violence and
there was also
beauty in the exchange of culture and
goods and ideas
and over time learning that the
other is actually the self
again a big part of our metaphysics and
that
if you do things like look at what
organizations like open
ai have actually achieved
you can look at our episode
on that featuring todor markov and what
you'll see
is you'll see that he explains to us
that open ai has simulated environments
called neural mmo
and in those environments what happens
is that the conscious agents over time
are bound in an environment and that
their
amount of interactions increase
as more and more of them spawn on the
bounded map that more and more of them
spawn
and they interact with each other more
and more frequently
so we've been doing this in artificial
intelligence
simulations of conscious agents on a
bounded map
these simulations that we run will
become
more and more important for us as we
gain the computational capacity
to simulate more and more of the
actual source code of the
reality as well as the conscious agents
interacting
in a graph theory environment
and that is currently the
work of donald hoffman which is his
conscious agent metaphysics which is
very exciting
highly recommend looking into that and
our interview with him
on the show as well okay
on we go to
number seven which is that
sentience deploys languages and
technologies
and this is another crucial part
that's right here sentience's
deployment of languages and technologies
because obviously the initial
technologies as we could describe as the
invention
of fire and writing
and art and the
initial grunts for language the
proto-language
and then the initial semiotics the
development of symbols
and meaning and the
development of the wheel and
all of those inventions
and our technologies and then over time
that the languages ended up
at around 7000 current languages but
there is a massive
planetary ethnographic condensation
occurring
like the anthropologist wade davis
taught us on the show you should also
watch that episode of
our interview with him in vancouver
and that over time the languages
are very very clearly becoming
concentrated
in the main planetary languages like
english and mandarin
and arabic and spanish
and so there's a power law distribution
and wade davis said that the
speed at which we are losing
a language on the planet is every two
weeks and there's a lot of profound
things for us to learn about
those native tongues that are
disappearing around the planet
so we should be investing more of our
resources
into anthropology and archaeology
across the planet in linguistics in
order to retain those
native tongues and to investigate them
because they may have
very important and profound aphorisms
and ideas that will be
extremely important in modernity
so eventually what occurs
is that
is that sentience
as especially it's developing its most
cutting edge technologies
including the ones that we have today
slowly begins to
[Music]
try and understand itself more and more
and so you have
you have here in eight the struggle
to understand itself again on this
evolutionary path
on the oroboros the struggle to
understand itself eight
and so my
understanding of that is that in the
last couple thousand years
what has happened is that we've had a
massive
effort in perennial spiritual philosophy
and mystic traditions and wisdoms
from the vedic rishis
to the ancient egyptians and
mesopotamians
and the chinese
and the taoists and the buddhists and
the abrahamic traditions
and the aborigines and the
african spiritual traditions and the
native american spiritual lineages and
what they thought was that
consciousness is
fundamental and that consciousness
is it that you are
it i and my father
are one john 10 30.
of the sanskrit tradition you are that
of the sufi metaphysics
the unity of all being in existence the
dao of taoism
advaita vedanta the atman
and the brahmana are one there
are a ridiculous
amount of pointings of
sentience really undergoing the process
of truly getting there over thousands of
years
and that just basically having
the most
fundamental issue of
discussing with one another over time
what that exact is and figuring out how
to properly co-exist
on that point number eight the struggle
to understand itself now
leading up to
more modern times what happened in the
last 500 years
is the obsession with
science and
that science is not a phenomenon that
was invented 500 years ago
science is a phenomenon that for
thousands of years
has been in practice over figuring out
how to most
effectively breed crops together
how to most effectively
study the nature of our own
consciousness and existence
so science is a much much older
phenomenon than just 500 years
and the true scientists
are those that investigate the nature of
their own consciousness
first as bentino massaro has been
promulgating as well
so i highly recommend watching his
mirror talks
series so
in the last 500 years specifically we've
had an obsession
with the investigation of
the quote exterior
and that that physicalism
of investigation has been
both
exciting in bringing
physical flourishing in meeting the
basic needs of people around the planet
with the nutrients of the seed
of the human just like we analogize in
high level perception to the
tree that we're able to meet those
nourishing
needs of the roots of the human with
basic
water and food and shelter
and clean air and love
and education and electricity and
technology and health care
and that's enabling the fruits of that
tree
of that seed of that human to blossom
and flourish so point number
eight is that science has enabled a lot
with the physicalism
very recently it's also made a strong
influence on the interior
to not be as much of a primary focus
and so we have many
spiritualists and philosophers
and people that study genius and people
that study
morals and ethics and awareness
and perception and reality that are
saying that we cannot
just study physicalism we must also
study the subject we must study
consciousness we must study awareness
and so in the process there is a big
synthesis that is happening right now
between physicalism and spirituality
and that synthesis of science and
spirituality is about to lead
to a massive renaissance and it's very
very exciting so sentience has struggled
to understand itself which is number
eight
and what's happened now is that we found
ourselves in
point number nine
so that's right here so point number
nine on the oroboros
we have passed many fermi filters
and we're slowly having our own nature
be
unveiled so
in essence we have
passed the asteroid fermi filter which
came
about 66 million years ago and wiped out
the
dinosaurs and we haven't really had that
problem too much
but that doesn't guarantee that it that
we should
not be prepared just in case
so we definitely should be and that
we have somewhat passed
the nuclear bombs
fermi filter which was
opened up to us about 75 years ago
and although
we are still struggling
to eradicate the over 10 000
nuclear weapons that are on the planet
the
proliferation
era of being the word of the day as tom
lehrer would say
is and who's next
being slowly over time
less and less of a problem because more
and more people are waking up to
mutually assure destruction being a
massive catastrophic issue and needing
to focus on mutually assured
peace as tristan tyler blake said
on our episode a couple days ago so
there's that fermi filter and then
we're in the middle of the fermi filter
of the anthropocene
right now so we are noticing the
and it's helpful for you guys to have
this visual asset
and this is the one from high level
perception chapter 10
on infinity in the bottom right corner
so we're in that
auroboros we got through the asteroid
we're
getting through the nuclear bomb we're
in the middle of the anthropocene which
is at the bottom
which we have to make sure that we get
through
the
the lack of foresight
of the interconnectedness and
interdependence of everything on the
planet and humans can't just
go and dump toxic waste into the rivers
because it enters the hydrological cycle
and that's why we had the epa formed
and that's why today we're having all of
the epp
problems the environmentally persistent
pharmaceutical pollutant issues in our
hydrological cycle
and that's why we need incentives for
long-term thinking
as there are places like the congo and
amazon
and brazil that are being incentivized
to think in short term
and destroy the biodiversity and the
carbon sequestration capacities of the
forest and the acidification
of the oceans where the phytoplankton
provide us with 70 percent of our o2
and we take 20
000 of those breaths of o2 every single
day
so we're waking up to the
interconnectedness
and then the other fermi filters which
is we're approaching here in these next
couple of decades is the biowarfare one
and then the agi one
so those are the those are the fermi
filters
and
sentience has yet to fully pass those
and as you know there's also the
kardashev scale
and that we are
not even at number one yet on the
kardashev scale which is the full
sustainable
life living on planet earth
we are still not sustainably living on
planet earth so we are approximately at
a point
seven on the kardashev scale and then to
be
at the next ranks on the kardashev scale
we need to
harvest harness the power of nuclear
fusion
that's mandatory absolutely
and those that are scientifically
literate know that it is
extremely possible to
and that it's our most abundant way
forward to
harness the power of fusing atoms more
taking out energy than we put in to
create the actual fusion and there's
great technologies that are being
developed like the stellarator right now
beyond the tokamak which is very
exciting and there's massive investments
that are happening
in that space which is very exciting
and that will help us tremendously as we
move forward
especially with desalination and
providing the basic need of water across
the planet
and enabling that more bountiful
abundant
future that all of our hearts know is
possible
so we are being in a sense we are being
we are being titrated
what the greeks called an amnesia which
is remembrance
and so from the godhead in a sense
we are being titrated this is our north
star up here
and we're being titrated
and amnesia remembrance and
the one of the big ideas
that for example igor lentermann was
just
on our show about on the semantic web
teaching us about that and his company
atomic search
and i highly recommend watching that
episode
and what he asked me was what was
the pattern of the 1000 plus
geniuses that i studied in
2020 and my answer to him
was that i think that the
meta pattern of genius
is that they reverse engineered
the godhead
so meaning that i think
that genius no matter where
they show up here
that genius sees this and whether it's
conscious
or subconsciously that they build and
architect
the source code deployments
those code updates that they
create to get us to this godhead
the portals that come to pull up the
rest of the bell curve
so the bell curve is always evolving
towards the godhead
and that's the
that's the star here in
high level perception chapter 4 portals
so the bell curve is
always evolving to the godhead and the
geniuses the visionaries are the ones
that are reverse
engineering that godhead in deploying
the and amnesia the remembrance the
titrated code updates to the
evolutionary pacer to upgrade people's
perception and awareness and
consciousness
more and more towards that recursive
godhead
so
what happens is that
there are all of these unveilings
that occur and that we can
very easily say that
many of these unveilings occurred
in that period of time of thousands of
years as i was mentioning earlier of
that perennial spiritual philosophy and
mystic traditions and wisdoms
as they were investigating their own
consciousness and awareness that those
were the unveilings of the nature of
reality at that time
but really all the way up to modernity
now more and more and more
whether we talk about the invention of
the model t or henry ford whether we
talk about the
invention of the airplane with the
wright brothers what's happened is that
it's enabled us to go around the planet
now there's a hundred thousand
commercial flights that happen around
the planet every single
day and more and more people as we've
globalized
have landed in different places around
the planet and they've looked
at other humans in the eyes directly
into their pupils
and they've breathed
and the other has also breathed
and they've realized the self
that they share that being
and that is eradicating xenophobia
that is creating more xenophilic people
people that love
foreign cultures
people that love the
beauty of all cultures
and
it's two-part the way that they see
that self is because they know
that we come from the same source and
this is
chapter eight the magic trick we all
come from that same
source
as sri aurobindo says diversity in
oneness
and then the second way we know
the self in the other
is this that the calculus
of consciousness
so it's synthesizing a principle from
physicalism
with spirituality
so we are the
integration of all of the infinitesimal
data of 0 to 8 billion
consciousness and 10 million species
all as a planetary organism
that integration that 99.9 percent
genetic similarity between humans
and the derivation the derivative the
differentiation
is the 0.1 percent of each unique
individual nerve ending acting as their
own
artist being their own
unique melody or instrument that is
being played
in the symphony of that oneness
so it's the oceanic integration
and the unique individuation
of the artistic expression and that's
the
synthesis of the east and the west
the unity with the individuation
and this is where i think we go beyond
non-duality
we go beyond non-duality to respect
the teachings of the west the beauty the
beauty of the individuation
because guess what
it is the individual
that is the portalist it's the
individual that deploys the code
updates to the evolutionary pacer and
augments their perception and upgrades
their consciousness
and many times that portal is that
individual is highly supported by
teams of dozens or hundreds or thousands
of other teammates that are helping
deploy these big
code updates as we are seeing currently
with
the technology of the automotive company
like tesla
okay
most though i would say
the current technologies that are
unveiling
our own nature to us
are the
field of virtual realities
because the augmented and the mixed
realities
are as well but specifically the virtual
realities because more and more
as they become indistinguishable
and the more that we enable ourselves
with bio and neuro technology
and we synthesize together in their
artificial general intelligence and
simulation theory the more that we put
those
fields together the more that we enter
into the virtual
designer realities in these next couple
of decades that are indistinguishable
and before you know it
that ready player one
is a documentary
that the idea of going
inward as we also saw in the black
mirror episode as well
is actually a documentary that we
see that we're going inward and we're
spending
days and weeks and months and years
in these indistinguishable virtual
worlds
and that we realize more and more as an
unveiling mechanism
to the nature of our own consciousness
and awareness that
this in itself this is a hypothesis a
metaphysical hypothesis that
this in itself is already that 80-year
virtual reality that we are playing
so we are building right now the most
unveiling mechanism
for the nature of our own
sentience and awareness and
consciousness
and other technologies that are like
that are
the blockchain and decentralization
technologies where you can literally see
things like bitcoin and ethereum
being literally modeled after mycelium
intelligence that's over a billion years
old
mycorrhizal networks that have a two-way
resource exchange with 95 percent of
plants
underground that enabled plants to
flourish
on land and in many ways that enabled
humans to flourish on land
that we are biomimicking that
decentralized
intelligence of mycelium it's embedded
in biology as an
archetype that's why the internet
evolved that is why the decentralization
technologies
that are borderless like bitcoin and
ethereum and the cryptocurrencies
are emerging and taking over the
corruption of the fiat currencies that
have had
massive beneficial
impact but also insanely detrimental
effect with the asymmetries like we saw
in the 2008 subprime mortgage crisis
where we have a massive
risk that the bankers take
and they have no skin in the game in
terms of
having the potential detriments
of the
downfall and so they can have the
benefit
but that they socialized the
as a tax on us to bail out
the banks a massive asymmetry no more
no more the decentralization revolution
is here that's another awakening
mechanism again
these are all awakening mechanisms the
more you
wake up and realize that
the entheogens unleashing the divine
within
that are found all around the planet
are secreted by us as codes that we
embedded so that they would wake us up
more
to the nature of reality just like we've
had with the internet
and just like we've had with the
spiritual revelations and just like
we've had with the decentralization
technology
so now we are at that stage where
sentience
has had more and more of its own nature
unveiled
okay so now
we are at 10 which is that
auroboros godhead and metaverse
recursion
so so this one
is very much so
right around the corner
so that's right up here number 10.
the oroboros godhead and metaverse
recursion right here
and so
what we hypothesize
is the actual nature of reality is that
as we discussed
the metaverse is the synthesis
of
mixed realities artificial general
intelligence simulation theory biotech
neurotech and as that all amalgamates
together
what occurs is these infinite designer
virtual worlds
and that you get to as a catalog
as a phenomenological
qualia catalog
for you to experience get to
immerse yourself into them and so that
is simply what this
is that this
is an iteration
a combinatoric of consciousness
exploring infinity in this
combinatoric this iteration
is simply the
four limb two eyed carbon-based dna
encoded
creatures these sole vehicles that we're
in that
that's the flavor
we can say chocolate and that you have
to use your imagination
to go beyond chocolate
and that is what these indistinguishable
virtual designer realities are of the
metaverse
all of the other flavors
and so that is what we hypothesize as
the metaverse recursion so
what happens is very simple
it's that at this godhead that we are
reverse engineering this north star
it's an amnesia remembrance
that what we're doing is we're entering
into the next
tales and the next tales are different
combinatorics the next tales
the next tales are
not this exact same one consciousness
has already
explored this iteration there are many
more iterations to explore
and if you watch the
benoit mandelbrots infinite fractal zoom
on maths town what you'll see
at that center point at that source
point is you'll see that we hypothesize
that actually in that top left corner
that that source light refracting
through that prism is an analogy that we
are using
for the speed at which these
iterations and combinatorics are being
made
at that speed
and so that is truly what consciousness
exploring infinity is
that's what we hypothesize and we are
but
one iteration and combinatoric
and it's beautiful it's beautiful
it's perfect we are the publishers and
players
there are no bugs there are only
features
it's what we designed
and it's what
we are waking up to is
the nature of our being
so
what i'll do is i will take you
now for the uh
brief review
again that
the actual nature of reality
being as a hypothesis the auroboros tale
the big bang that source code automata
the bounding function sentience evolving
ordering chaos languages and
technologies evolving
the struggle to understand ourself
passing fermi filters
unveiling our own nature and the
auroboros godhead
metaverse recursion okay
so what i'll do is i will take you to
the last
module where i've tried to create one
more
visualization for you
and i've talked about this already
that we are consciousness exploring
infinity three words
our metaphysics is three words
consciousness
exploring infinity you can also say
source
exploring infinity and
three words is the metaphysics so
and sri aurobindo and the mother mural
fossa also use
the diversity in oneness
which is another great three words those
are our
second three words that we're using for
our metaphysics
so consciousness exploring infinity and
diversity and oneness which you can see
there is the second
point there and i'll go ahead and i'll
show you this graphic where i also
illustrate the
deterministic recursive telos with that
bayesian cloud and also that candy store
analogy
that we learned from donald hoffman
okay and so in this graphic you can see
that all we're doing is we're trying to
look at that same
auroboros and we're just trying to look
at it from another perspective
okay so the same boros that we looked on
the first graphic but just from another
perspective and so what we're showcasing
here
is that this is that that starting point
of that tail
and how we programmed in the recursive
telos
so this godhead
this godhead right here is programmed
in to the recursive telos
right so this the godhead of recursive
telos is programmed into the tail
start so the tail start has the
recursive telos of the godhead
programmed in it now the difference is
this is not a deterministic
system this is like robert may's
logistic map
which what that means is that this
entire space
here is a big bayesian cloud
so what you have to do is you have to
you have to do things like
attempt you have to attempt to
bring bring in other fields
from physicalism from in this sense
quantum mechanics
the electron cloud and in this case what
we're trying to do is create an analogy
and where there are the dense areas in
the quantum mechanical electron cloud
that similar analogy can be used for the
oroboros process
of the
conscious agents
the diverse conscious agents in oneness
so there's that second point diversity
diversity in oneness
and that this big bayesian cloud space
has
dense spots on it which as this
diversity and oneness dynamically
evolves the dense spots also
change over time and and the
darwinian metaphysics comes into play
where the possibility if these if we
do not get our [ __ ] together we may fall
to some of the fermi filters and not
reach
the godhead and so that's the
illustration here
that you have the diversity you have the
oneness
so diversity is that blue the oneness is
that purple
and that the in that the beijing cloud
is this red pink
again so we have the bayesian cloud as
the pink and that
red as the recursive telos that is
programmed into
the tail start that then
is evolving towards the godhead but that
has a massive creative possibility space
okay all right i'm glad that
i was also able to to share
that with you another visual another
visualization of consciousness exploring
infinity
and again i highly recommend watching
the interview with donald hoffman
who's doing the conscious agent
metaphysics right now the actual math
behind that and he brings up the candy
store analogy which is very fascinating
which we mentioned a little bit earlier
as well
so this iteration this combinatoric
is just chocolate and that we are going
into the infinite designer realities to
explore all of the other possibilities
in that infinite candy store of tastes
and that's another fascinating
revelation to me
i believe it was just two days ago on
the program we've been asking
quote silly questions at the end of the
show and one of the silly questions we
ask is
what is your favorite food
i didn't actually realize that that was
a metaphysical question
but it is because the same way
that conscious agents have diverse
preferences in taste
is the same way that we as consciousness
have diverse preference in taste
of phenomenological experience
mind blown and that's why
we go in again on the metaverse level
there's going to be many many different
combinatorics
and iterations to explore and
it's going to be beautiful and that's
why
sir roger penrose noble laureate in
physics in 2020
believes in cyclic cosmology which is
fascinating
and this is his quote which is which is
in our
chapter 10.
this is very exciting stuff that this is
that this is in mainstream
mainstream now guys it's exciting
there was something before the big bang
and that something
is what we will have in our future
sir roger penrose
it's super exciting and he's actually
working with uh stuart ameroff and
a bunch of the other
synthesis in the field of physicalism
and
consciousness spirituality which is very
exciting
so that is that is it
um that's it there's these there were
these modules again
that loving balance of perpetual
kindergarten
and metaphysical insight and
encouragement for those that are trying
simplifying using
art thinking integrally using your
imagination
thinking cyclically especially on the
purpose
incorporating infinity eternity
consciousness that actual nature of
reality
it's a very very exciting trying to map
out that
actual oroboros in detail
for us over time this will evolve and we
will become better
at this using higher
quality animation teams get to that in
just a moment
and then d module consciousness
exploring infinity that diversity and
oneness that big bayesian cloud of
creative possibilities as we go to that
godhead
and all of the infinite tastes in the
candy store
so so yeah
so it's it's gonna be awesome
here in los angeles as you've seen we've
been doing so many of these powerful
interviews
so far and that we're only at the
beginning
the entirety of the bottom of the
iceberg has yet to be
excitingly artistically expressed by
our show here and many of the things
that are there are not just these
interviews
and not just these these fun
graphical artistic
representations of what we think is
and feel is the nature of existence
consciousness reality maximizing human
potential
but that we also are excited to leverage
our capacities out here in the mimetic
capital of the planet
to disseminate
animations series anthologies
documentaries more content and we're in
discussions right now
on building out that three space
for our 2021 animated series which is
very
very exciting which we will
be excitingly centered
around awakening especially young
people to the investigation of their own
reality and consciousness which is
super duper duper exciting so
this has been a another
uh attempt
to distill artistically
the actual nature of reality
a hypothesis at what we
think and feel it is
and we'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
please let us know how you feel about
this and
also feel free to build on top of it
feel free to make content yourselves
about this and we would love to
over time be more and more
close artistically in our distillations
to what
the actual nature of reality is
so also like the video
subscribe share the video with other
people especially people that you know
are further up on that bell curve
interested
in the nature of consciousness and
awareness and reality and maximizing
potential send this especially to them
and hopefully we can even get some
people
closer to that center part of the bell
curve like hmm what were some of those
concepts let me go look them up and then
maybe they go and attend
some of the actual practices where they
go and
do the inner investigation which is
exciting
so and i just again i just highly
encourage us to use
art in our distillations and i highly
encourage us to support
the the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the scientists and
engineers that are actually trying to
maximize human potential that are
actually trying to
uncover the nature of reality and
existence and being
and shoot portals into the center of the
bell curve acting as those code updates
and those upgrades
for the rest of society to awaken
so support them you can support us our
links are in the bio below
and that's it everyone go and build the
future manifest your dreams in the world
self-actualize
and self-realize both
achieve the north star and
have consciousness fully fully
understand its own nature
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in we'll see you soon
peace
you